hi i'm eric boston deadpool 2 followed
up its first movie with even more great
bits and clever little jokes that you
might have missed and you know deadpool
is so meta himself that this movie
almost breaks itself down as it goes hey
what gives pool
this is all i have and not worried
deadpool can break all the fourth walls
he wants
this screen will always be closer to
your face that's what counts you know
now that we're a thing
let's cozy up re-watch deadpool 2 steam
by scene and point out all the subtle
details and easter eggs that you
could overlook the first time around
maybe you caught some of these
references already but you know you
gotta be sure
don't you don't chat spoilers ahead and
let's get started with the opening image
deadpool winds up a music toy this is
wolverine impaled on a stump just like
he is at the end of logan this whole
movie jabs at logan and nearly every
superhero movie but the opening and
closing scenes really go after it
deadpool's severed arm flips us off as
he says
wolverine for riding his coattails with
an r rating and killing off the hero
many believe that fox studios only
allowed logan to have an r rating
because of deadpool's wild success
it's an r-rated superhero movie and yeah
deadpool promises he's gonna end the
same way logan did blowing himself up
here is a fake-out of course
this isn't how he dies but in the
explosion we actually get a
foreshadowing of how that happens the
inhibitor collar this one has been
modified to have deadpool's logo on it
but deadpool is already sneakily
revealing to us how he will later use
this collar to inhibit his regeneration
powers so he can take the bullet for
wrestle
seeing deadpool go to these lengths to
kill himself is actually a gag that was
removed from the first deadpool movie
script after wade's freak experiment
deforms his skin the writers planned for
a groundhog day style suicide montage
they cut it because it came off as too
jokey for that story beat but it's fun
to see the guy come back in the sequel
we also get a callback to
wade's blue croc sandals and the song
that plays here is all out of love by
air supply that could be a nod to ryan
reynolds seen in van wilder
[Music]
i'm so lost without you then deadpool
rewinds six months earlier
showing his global killing spree fun
detail here the neon sign on the
building rooftop has these chinese
characters
thanks to google translate i was able to
translate them to dead
and pool he listens to his walkman to
work himself up to the kill a callback
to him doing so in the first movie there
it was
shoot by salt and peppa here it's dmx's
x gonna give it to you which was kind of
the theme song of that first movie he
calls his target by identifying himself
as gail
that could be a reference to gail simone
a writer of the deadpool comics and set
to dolly parton's 9-5 deadpool
slaughtering these sex traffickers
featured some
impressive fight choreography this
movie's director was david leach he
co-directed john wick and he can
definitely see the parallels deadpool
pops up out of a casket to take out some
more targets something he does in the
comics but he says do not
go in there referencing the line from
east ventura do not
go in there whoa you know come to think
deadpool might be the closest thing in
the movies right now to the physical
comedy jim carrey performed in the 90s
deadpool accidentally enclosed the guy
in the spa
calling him scoutmaster kevin later he
and vanessa agree that the name kevin
for their kid sounds too strippery i
feel like both of these could be nods to
marvel studios head kevin feige there's
also a quick shot of deadpool posing as
an erotic dancer in a strip club and if
you look closely among the drink
specials is
burning bastards mc bernie and bastard's
mc is also the name of an erotic book
series classified as
alpha biker romance to each her own and
as deadpool describes this sequel as a
family film that opens with a tragic
death in the vein of bambi the lion king
or
saw7 he taps his watch this is his
adventure time watch that we saw him
wearing in the first film the end of the
movie he ends up bequeathing it onto
domino
outside deadpool outruns this mob
begging dopinder to start the getaway
taxi this could be an odd to the bit at
the beginning of raiders of the lost
ark depender doesn't hear him because
he's listening to an audio tape of
motivational speaker tony robbins
depender surprisingly has a full
character arc of his own in this movie
it starts with tony robbins promising
him that with confidence he can pull
something off like never before and yeah
the movie ends with dopinder following
through on that
in the taxi deadpool says his mission
was accomplished in a
george w kind of way reminding us of a
certain premature celebration that
blew up in bush's face just like this
failure will blow up in wade's space in
a few minutes
he also mentions the passion of the
christ pointing out that the first
deadpool nearly surpassed it as the
highest grossing rated movie ever
but it only beat it internationally not
in america where seeing deadpool get
violently ripped to bits is just a
little less exciting than seeing it
happen to jesus meanwhile deadpool
refers to dopinder as goose
who's the co-pilot to maverick in the
movie top gun while dependent maps the
relationship on another tom cruise movie
interview with a vampire
identifying with kirsten dunst kirsten
dunst
kirsten and in case you missed it the ad
on top of dependers taxi is for alpha
flight alpha flight is the name of a
canadian spin-off of the x-men one of
the many nods to ryan reynolds canadian
nationality
actually some fan theories speculate
that the alpha flight might be the
friendly canadians that the kids at the
end of logan might be headed north of
the border to when he comes home to
vanessa one of wade's excuses was
fighting a caped badass until he
discovered his mom was named martha too
yeah pretty obviously
batman be superman save
martha and then he presents her with
this token of love
a literal token from the arcade that
they went to on their first date
recalling one of the best visual jokes
in the first movie it's time to put
balls in holes
you said whatever i want i get it
he loves people obviously this coin
plays an important role in the movie's
ending now back in those days wade and
vanessa joked about watching
clown porn here the porn they watch is
the movie yentl
starring barbra streisand who sings papa
can you hear me which
way you observe sounds a lot like do you
want to build a snowman from frozen
papa can you hear
me do you wanna build a snowman
wade also compares his daddy issues to
those of luke skywalker and star wars
alluding to luke's weird romantic
chemistry with his sister leia vanessa
corrects him that the kiss happened
in empire which is a callback to the
first movie just ride a bitch's back
like yoda and luke
oh star wars jokes empire now vanessa's
shocking murder leads to this awesome
opening credit sequence
inspired by the sort you'd see at the
beginning of a james bond movie celine
dion's ashes even sounds a lot like
adele's skyfall now there are actually a
ton of little visual references in the
sequence notice how the hilt of the
falling katana shows
be deadpool has named his katanas b and
arthur for
be arthur of golden girl's a longtime
passion of his also the barrel of his
pistol reads smile wait for the flash
like you would see in a photo booth and
he restages the move for the movie flash
dance but with bullet casings and like
the opening sequence of the first movie
all the credits are little jokes
including cinematography by blind al
and directed by one of the guys who
killed john wick's dog for david leech
but my favorite part of this credit
sequence is the way it again foreshadows
the ending notice how we see cable's
teddy bear which remembers how cable and
the rest know of the status of the
future kind of like marty mcfly's photo
of his family also the camera flies
through
deadpool's fatal gunshot hole the exact
spot where he takes the bullet for
russell and at the very end of the
sequence we see a bullet flying through
a stack of arcade tokens foreshadowing
the very end of the movie in which cable
spares deadpool's light by blocking the
bullet with the lead rk token okay
moving on while mourning vanessa and
sister margaret's wade says george
michael was right we're never going to
dance again this is a callback to the
george michael song at the end of the
first movie when he and vanessa came
together
later with blind al in his apartment
wade digs cocaine out of the floorboards
underneath the coke you can see the cure
for blindness this is also a call back
to the first movie when he handed this
to blind out
there's about 116 kilos of cocaine
buried somewhere in the apartment
right next to the cure for blindness
blindow tells wade that he has to keep
living and he calls her mcconaughey
referencing matthew mcconaughey's famous
line from jason confused you just gotta
keep living man
l-i-v-i-n after deadpool blows himself
up colossus returns to bring him to the
x-mansion
now the shirt that wade wears after his
recovery shows two cats with the caption
olivia and meredith together forever
olivia and meredith are taylor swift's
cats and i hope that shirt goes out of
style naked sonic teenage warhead
returns with a new haircut and a
girlfriend yukio hi yukio
wade calls her pinkie pie for my little
pony and then winks at the camera
hinting that he might be among the brony
subculture and you know what no trigger
warning looking that up it's a very
wholesome thing to be a part of i'm
saying i'm part of it but it's
okay and yeah this whole sequence is
filled with references to the x-men
movies
wade ditches colossus's lecture
hijacking professor x's wheelchair
and then he calls back the great joke
from the first movie about
fox not wanting to pay for better x-men
cameos with the camera now revealing
all of the x-men cameos in the
background we can see james mcavoy as
charles xavier nicholas holt as hank
mccoy beast
evan peters as quicksilver ty sheridan
as scott summers cyclops and the new
versions of storm and nightcrawler from
x-men apocalypse yes i know the timeline
doesn't totally make sense here these
are all the younger 80s versions of the
characters but guys it's deadpool he's
aware of both mcavoy and stewart
versions of professor x timeline logic
doesn't apply to you
wade also mentions uh putts with the
giant pigeon wings referring to angel
either the ben foster version the last
stand or the more recent one from
apocalypse he also wears the cerebro
helmet
saying that it smells like patrick
stewart now during this section we meet
cable played by josh brolin pulling
double duty along with thanos over in
the mcu
in the comics cable is nathan summers
the son of jean grey and scott summers
though it was on that like clones of
them look guys it's best not to think
too hard about cable because the comics
version of cable is deliberately over
the top
he's infected by a techno-organic virus
giving him cybernetic parts and he like
time travels as often as i use the
bathroom
i drink a lot of coffee now cable led
the x-force but really the best thing
about him in the comics in my opinion is
when he teams up with deadpool it's
really one of the best marble pairings
ever and he's like a perfect choice to
come into the sequel
in the movie they've made cable a
time-traveling assassin on a mission to
kill a kid before he destroys the future
this is essentially the baby hitler
premise
something deadpool references later in
the movie and rumor has it is actually
part of the movie's post-credit montage
before it was deleted it's also the plot
of the ryan johnson movie looper with an
old grouchy bruce willis coming back in
time to kill a super powered kid who
later turns evil and kills his wife in
the future the time travel device that
cable uses resembles a watch but not
just
any watch look closely that is a carl f
booger brand booker watches were
featured heavily in john wick
2 the movie david leach worked on right
before making deadpool 2. and yeah cable
in this movie comes off a lot like the
terminator the t800 played by arnold and
the t-1000 and t2
he arrives back in time asking what year
is it and he robs and kills some goofy
locals just like the terminators do in
those movies by the way those two
rednecks are celebrity cameos on the
right is alan tudyk and the fatty on the
left is matt damon
under a lot of makeup in the credits he
goes by his character name and the
talent of mr ripley i don't know guys
after his cameo and thor ragnarok matt
damon's kind of becoming the stan lee of
all these movies except you know like
not having created all these characters
the terminator parallels continue
later when cable does a one-handed spin
reload while blowing crap up in the
icebox just like arnold's signature move
in t2 and later when cable repairs
himself while staring coldly in the
mirror like the scene in the first
terminator another fun detail when cable
assembles his gun he includes a dial
that goes up to 11
a reference to the movie this is spinal
tap the numbers all go
to 11. but let's get back to deadpool he
joins the x-men as a trainee responding
to an incident at the essex house of
mutant rehabilitation now the name is a
reference to nathaniel essex aka
sinister a major villain from the x-men
comics the news reporter on the scene
is irene merriweather of whit now irene
merriweather is actually a name for the
marvel comics she is an investigative
reporter on the run for the murderous
hellfire club and she becomes a romantic
interest to cable irene shows up again
later briefly in the news helicopter
that shreds shatterstar to green goo
also if you look closely at the news
ticker on the broadcast one headline
reports
christopher plummer refused to do
reshoots in deadpool 2. now this is a
nod at the recent movie all the money in
the world in which christopher plummer
re-shot major portions of the movie to
replace kevin spacey
who was cut from the movie after his
scandal now some people are saying this
could be a reference to the controversy
surrounding tj miller i'm not sure about
that
outside this mutant rehab orphanage is
russell collins aka firefist firefist is
a mutant from the x-factor comics and
he's played here by julian dennison best
known for the movie hunt for the wilder
people the soldiers responding to this
crisis are the dmc
probably for a department of mutant
control or containment they appear to be
a movie version of the mutant response
division from the x-men comics as
deadpool shows up he describes the x-men
as a dated metaphor for racism in the
60s
he's referencing stan lee conceiving the
early x-men story lines as responses to
the civil rights movement of the 1960s
in the 2000s the x-men movies were seen
as metaphors for lgbt rights russell
calls negasonic justin bieber keeping up
the tradition of the nicknames for her
after obstinate o'connor and ripley from
alien 3 in the first movie and then
there's this exchange
come quietly or there will be trouble
you stole that from robocop robocop this
is also a callback to when deadpool
compared colossus to robocop in the
first movie
dead or alive you're coming with me when
russell blast deadpool to a nearby
apartment he autographs a box of hero
flakes which has hugh jackman's
wolverine on the front he signs it as
ryan reynolds with the deadpool logo
then he jumps out and says superhero
landing coming up and he struggles to
get to his feet after the superhero
landing this is a call back to the first
movie when deadpool mocks the whole idea
of this superhero landing
she's gonna do a superhero landing
superhero landing yeah that's really
hard on your knees
deadpool also makes his four or five
moments hero speech he's quoting
colossus from the first movie
four or five moments that's all it takes
two i like how both speeches end with
deadpool just ain't screw it and
shooting bad guy
this leads to wade and russell getting
incarcerated in the icebox now the
icebox is an actual prison in the marvel
comics for superhumans
it's located in canada deep in the
northwest territories when wade arrives
he asks if there's a sorting hat for
gangs referencing the sorting hat of
hogwarts and harry potter now i like the
detail that while wearing the inhibitor
collar wade's cancer returns it's just a
reminder that wade's regeneration
mutation didn't
cure him of cancer it just regenerates
the cells that were killed by the cancer
and allows him to live with it
and wade throws shade at the mcu saying
give me a bow and an arrow and i'm
basically hawkeye mocking clint barton's
relative powerlessness
compared to the other avengers then we
meet black tom cassidy he's also from
the x-men in the deadpool comics he's a
mutant who drives energy through plant
life now he's irish and he's a black
sheep of his clan thus the name
but yeah it's still kind of weird to
have a character named black tom who's
not black when cable breaks into the ice
box wade throws more mcu's shade by
describing cable as the old
with the winter soldier arm and then he
doubles up on this by later asking cable
at what point will audiences say enough
with the robotic arms referring to not
only cable and winter soldier but yeah
probably also characters like claw and
black panther and nebula in the
guardians movies he also digs at dc
comparing cable's serious attitude to
something out of zack snyder's over
dramatic lens
so dark are you sure you're not from the
dc universe and speaking of dc when
cable asks who wade is he does his best
michael keaton impression
i'm batman oh yeah sure but um you know
he also said it in the movie
i'm batman yep that's the one deadpool
also calls one of cable's utility
pouches a fanny pack
saying he had one of them in 1990 never
this could be a joke about the early 90s
cable in x-force comics in which artist
rob liefeld strapped characters with a
ridiculous number of pouches
for some reason so many accessories
jumping ahead later russell makes
friends with the monster in the icebox
basement whom we later learn is
juggernaut he says they can be gangsters
like tupac and ice cube
and hunt for the wilder people julian
dennison's character is obsessed with
tupac which is what he named his dog
later as deadpool and weasel assemble
the x-force if you look closely at their
stack of headshots you can see a picture
of a woman this is supreme court justice
ruth bader ginsburg i'm glad to know she
was being considered now the team that
gets assembled includes bedlam
played by terry crews he says his power
is to distort electricity including
nerve indians to make us feel things he
shows up in the x-force comics there's
also zeitgeist played by bill skarsgard
he also played pennywise in it last year
he spews acidic vomit
he's also from the x-force comics then
there's shatter star played by lewis tan
as is the case in the comics shatter
star comes from the mojo world where he
fights as a gladiator celebrity for a tv
network run by mojo
notice how his head shots in this movie
are of him shirtless that could be a
joke about tan's fitness modeling
and now that you've unpaused the video
yeah i know what you're doing we can
move on to the vanisher whom we learn
later is played by
brad freaking pitt and you could stop
pausing the video then there's domino
played by zazie beats her power is
luck to be specific to sense the outcome
events and then use that to her
advantage
in the comics she has a black mark over
her eye like a domino in this movie
daisy beats is of course black so they
reversed it with a white mark over her
eye
like another domino while arguing with
her over whether luck is even a
superpower deadpool
says mario lopez which is a callback to
wade's connection to mario lopez he read
his autobiography in the first movie and
he tackled mario during an access
hollywood episode to announce deadpool's
r rating and then of course there's
peter
a normal dude with no powers played by
comedian rob delaney who had been
running an amazing twitter account for
the character weeks before he was even
revealed in the role
seeing the x-force come together and
then like fall apart was the highlight
of the movie for me the whole audition
scene reminded me a lot of the movie
mystery men which has its own casting
calls scene for oddball non-heroes like
this movie and this idea of a montage of
aggro types leading to their abrupt
deaths is something that we saw in the
movie macgruber i could watch this stuff
over and over now there's a really cool
detail with these characters headshots
that was one of my favorite
foreshadowing moves in the movie and
i'll get to that in a second but first
real quick thanks to our sponsor
skillshare for helping us make this
video skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of classes and
design business technology and more its
premium membership gives you unlimited
access to high quality classes on
must-know topics so you can improve your
skills and unlock new opportunities and
do the work that you love now the work i
love
is writing yes in addition to hosting i
also write and research these videos and
it gets lonely but you know it's all for
you one skillshare course that really
helped me was emily
gould's creative writing for all a
10-day journaling challenge just a
really good exercise if you do any kind
of writing so you can notice your own
habits and keep yourself productive with
bigger projects
skillshare is also more affordable than
most learning platforms out there an
annual subscription is less than ten
dollars a month
but we're even going to do a special
offer for you guys the first 500 people
to sign up with the link in the
description below will get their first
two months for
free just go to skl.sh newrockstars4
or click on the link in the description
okay back to the point i was making
before notice how every time they add a
member to the team
they pin their head shot of the wall
with a knife now the exception is domino
for which they use a little tack
the knives foreshadow the x-force
members who die
in the next sequence domino with just
attack is the only new member to survive
when deadpool debriefs him on the plan
he uses his hand-drawn and crayon map
in the upper corner in the mountains he
drew a little wolverine in a cage a
reference to wolverine's time locked up
at alkali lake and deadpool labels them
with prisoner 24601
a reference to hugh jackman when he
played jean valjean in les miserables
also he wrote sequel money and pointed
to the city a meta joke about how the
sequel's budget was
way higher than what they got in the
first movie allowing them to shoot this
huge elaborate action sequence in the
chase scene and deadpool describes cable
as
511 not like in the comics he's
referencing josh borland's real life
height
which is shorter than ryan reynolds
who's 6-2 in the comics cable towers
over deadpool and then there's the words
no need for a third act this is a
filmmaking joke a lot of action movies
have big second act sequences and if the
hero's plan were to succeed the movie
could just
end early but these big plans have to
fail for a
third act to even be necessary on the
helicopter deadpool officially names him
the x-force saying he wanted a
gender-neutral alternative to x-men
domino calls that derivative which is a
joke about the x-force comics in the
late 80s the series totally was a
derivative attempt to reinvigorate the
x-men series
and right before the jump he turns to
camera and says laird hit it now laird
is the name of the costume guy who helps
ryan reynolds get in and out of his
deadpool costume on set
reynolds actually gave laird a shout out
in that preview scene that played before
logan
did i play speak with laird no
okay no just tell him wade called thank
you ac dc's thunderstruck plays as a
skydive leading to
the amazing death montage of each of the
x-force members
we get to know them and then they all
die it's great
i love that this movie finally showed
how hard it is to stage a coordinated
parachute landing a fast and furious
movie saw a group parachute with
cars and they all ended up fine yeah
sure
i'm just kidding i love the movies
deadpool gets snagged on a billboard
reading puppet show today at noon
notice how he hangs kind of like a
marionette right next to those words so
yeah bedlam shatterstar
zeitgeist and peter all kaput here same
for vanisher revealing brad pitt in the
flesh
as deadpool surveys his body count he
passes an ice cream truck reading prior
streets this is a reference to madeleine
pryor from the x-men comics she was that
clone of jean grey that i mentioned
before
the one who became cable's mother moving
on to the epic street chase which weasel
mentioned earlier takes place on
jerry duggan parkway jerry duggan is a
comic book writer who's written a lot of
recent deadpool issues domino also
passes a street called
bittini boulevard that's for ashley
bettini a visual effects artist who
worked on the movie
domino also passes some street art now
it's hard to tell but this is the face
of stan lee
the one cameo he does make in this movie
just not in person unfortunately
deadpool chases behind domino on this
stolen red scooter
this is a direct reference to deadpool
issue number 68 when he does this
and while he mocks domino's luck based
powers he says
what kind of comic book artist came up
with that gesture he probably can't draw
feet he's referring to deadpool
co-creator rob liefeld who co-created
cable and domino as well
lifebelt's character designs have often
been criticized for
impractical proportions and yes either
non-existent or just really weird
looking feet oh and don't forget the
pouches
so many accessories when cable boards a
truck he calls for
russell with his full name russell
collins and the deadpool shouts hands
off that kid john connor this is another
terminator joke and t2 the t-1000 was
looking all over for john connor to kill
him
girls you know john connor
cable shoves a bunch of the other mutant
containers off the rig the one mutant
who begs them not to
is a cameo by the director david leach
then deadpool confronts cable calling
him
one-eyed willy this is a reference to
josh brolin in the goonies when he
played shawn aston's older brother
looking for the treasure of the pirate
one-eyed willie
haven't you ever heard of that guy
what's his name the pirate guy
one-eyed willie also fun fact seconds
before teenage thanos says this he did
this
then cable fires at deadpool who
recreates his classic move from x-men
origin slicing the bullet in half
though here he tries to do it over and
over and he misses a few because that's
how it would go down when the truck
flips
deadpool's slow motion teabags cable a
callback to the still image teabag that
deadpool delivers in the opening shot of
the first movie
and deadpool using the toy version of
himself to tea bag toy cable in the
trailer in the wreckage we get the
reveal of
juggernaut now juggernaut is a long time
x-men character
and an unstoppable force at top speed he
was played cringingly by vinnie jones in
the last stand
in this movie the motion capture and
voice are performed by ryan reynolds
himself deadpool geeks out of her median
juggernaut naming a few specific comic
book issues and uncanny x-men number 103
juggernaut and black tom
trapped the x-men in thor 411 we learned
that juggernaut is capable of
withstanding blows from thor's hammer
and an x-men unlimited 12 juggernaut is
really the main character of that one
after juggernaut rips him half
domino carries his pieces like a
backpack which feels like a reference to
chewie carrying c-3po's pieces on his
back and empire strikes back
empire strikes backpack back at the
apartment wade's lower half regenerates
giving us his super unsettling tiny
naked body gag
calling back wade's regenerating baby
hand in the first movie don't worry
we won't show the full shot here nor
will we pan down on me what this uh
studio gets stuffy wade stuffed unicorn
returns we know from the first movie
what he uses that for
the shirt he's wearing is another
goonies reference that is the same shirt
that chunk wears in the goonies wade
calls domino black black widow comparing
her lucky survivor skills to that of
black widow in the mcu
but when cable appears deadpool
uncrosses his baby legs to flash him
weasel underlines the joke here by
calling this wade's basic instinct and
he's nodding at sharon stone doing that
one thing anyone remembers about basic
instinct and cable's explanation of
russell's dark future right before adult
russell kills cable's family he whispers
the words
blessed are the wicked who are healed by
my hand now in different scenes we hear
this phrase spoken to russell by that
creepy headmaster
russell ends up co-opting this idea as
his own dark catch phrase
on the taxi ride deadpool finishes the
story by sane and that's why you never
eat a raw starfish just common sense now
it kind of comes off as a non-sequitur
but yeah considering starfish can
regenerate their severed parts like
deadpool can
maybe wade once ate a raw starfish and
it grew into a new starfish in his
stomach
deadpool tries to get colossus to rejoin
his team by holding this iphone with a
boombox image on it while playing peter
gabriel's your eyes
it's an obvious reference to say
anything and then as russell and
juggernaut walk up to the essex house
juggernaut says that he wears the helmet
to protect himself from his brother
who's in a wheelchair this is a
reference to juggernaut's backstory he
actually is charles xavier's brother
juggernaut wears the helmet to stop
charles from using his telepathy to get
inside his head and then when deadpool
and the others show up to stop him
deadpool snaps at cable zip at thanos
shortly after he jumps on juggernaut's
head and tries to take him down making
another mcu reference saying
the sun's getting real low this is a
reference to avengers age of ultron and
thor ragnarok when black widow and thor
try to calm down the hulk by saying
these words and stroking his palm
it didn't work for thor and yeah it
doesn't work with deadpool deadpool also
says go get him tiger which is something
mary jane says in the spiderman comics
and it's the final line spoken by
kirsten dunst kirsten kerfer
and spider-man 2. the first deadpool
movie referenced it as well
let's our head to the back go get her
tiger after deadpool dives in to take
the bullet for russell
set to the music of tomorrow from annie
he quips that his heart was in the right
place
now in those heaven visions throughout
the movie vanessa had said these words
to wade too
and it's super satisfying to see their
meaning go from metaphorical and
thematic and general to
literal and specific in these final
moments wade's heart being directly in
the path of that bullet
is what saves everyone and as he dies
and wrestles arms you might recognize
the sad music here
[Music]
this is the same exact music that plays
at the end of logan as
he dies in laura's arm the track is
called don't be what they made you by
composer marco baltrami
oh this is what it feels
just like the beginning of deadpool was
a commentary on logan the final moments
of the movie are deadpool parodying it
with his own
drawn out dramatic death now speaking of
music in case you were wondering what
song that was while wade joins vanessa
and heaven this is aha's take on me but
an acoustic cover by lars horntveth
recorded at a live mtv
unplugged in norway last year
[Music]
but of course wade doesn't stay dead
cable decides to use his last time
travel charge to
go back in time and save deadpool in
case he missed it he goes back precisely
to the moment when deadpool had earlier
said
i wish i could turn back time and take
all that back cable drops another detail
he says that the bear belonged to his
daughter whose name is
hope now in the marvel comics hope
summers is the first mutant born after
the decimation event
a girl that cable takes on as a daughter
it isn't actually
really his daughter cable slips in
deadpool's suit the lead arcade coin
that he stole from him earlier which
later deflects the bullet
and in this revised timeline as they
walk away dopinder fulfills his
confidence arc by mowing down the
headmaster deadpool makes one final
mcu reference by calling him brown
panther and then the credits roll now
there's actually one
last missible detail in the final frame
but real quick the post credit scenes do
include some more little jokes
references to 11 from stranger things
deadpool going back in time to fix the
timeline of x-men origins by killing an
earlier
crappy version of himself and ryan
reynolds as he reads a green lantern
script
and yeah one last canada shout out but i
go into all of those details in my
post-credits scene breakdown video so go
check that out but
back to that final shot before the
credits roll some of you may have caught
this but if you look
very closely at the swimming pool in the
background you can barely see
juggernaut's dome
helmet as he rises out of the pool
perhaps this means a return in deadpool
3 or an x-force movie if those are still
in the works but either way i suppose
that pool
ain't a dead one a question for you guys
which josh brolin do you prefer
cable or thanos comment down below with
your thoughts and if you have some
deeper questions about this movie's
ending do not worry keep an eye out for
my other video explaining the deeper
questions about the ending
cables travel through time where wade
actually went when he was with vanessa
and the movie's general deeper meaning
you can also tweet me directly at eavos
or follow new rockstars on twitter for
updates on our videos
like and share this video subscribe to
new rockstars for all of our deadpool
and superhero movie deep dives thank you
for watching me
ruin this movie for myself by explaining
the [ __ ] out of it
i hate myself maximum effort
you